she thought it was so responsible of him
to make that move because of my
continual refusal to see how this stuff
is a waste of money can I guess the next
paragraph So after the honeymoon I said
I'm not texting your mama yeah
guys summer is in full swing which means
there's no better time to get out and
explore and just in time electric is
bringing you a fast and fresh new ride
the XP 3.0 their latest e-bike model
featuring new hydraulic brakes
ReDiscover your Independence this summer
with an XP 3.0 from Electric visit
electricebikes.com to learn more and
explore the Epic models electric has to
offer that's
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com we want to say
a big thank you to our sponsor fitbod
look you are not the same person you
were when the year started so it's
natural for your fitness journey to have
its ups and downs right ever you are in
your fitness journey get the most out of
every workout with fitbot get 20 off
your subscription at fitbod.me DPT
that's
fitbod.me Dept
love that hey townies welcome to another
episode of dumb people Town population
Ein binder Ein binder the third what's
up the third are you the third and we
make you wow women get the third the
first and the last oh geez okay I'm the
last one they broke the mold [__]
it's there's nowhere to go but down
there's nowhere to go but down the Matt
Lauer story
oh yeah I'm the last
It's a lazy boy and it's stained and it
was found on the street on uh you know
bulky item pickup day but it is yours
but it's but it's phone it's home it's
family it's family it's comfy it's comfy
yes there's a spring that's going to be
up your ass and yes when you pull the
lever you're all the way back there is
no mid-range but it's like if I'm
sleeping let's go all the way back let's
go all the way back that's Hannah's new
uh the title of her new comedy album
let's go all the way back I have a story
yeah let's do a story people do dumb
[__] we try to do I'm ready we try and
defeat it with comedy and I'm so happy
you're here to do this this was sent in
by Matthew Friedman at not your average
Matt reminder to all you Friends dumb
people Town hashtag hashtag dumb
peoplezone that's the way to say it at
school Brothers
it lets us know when you put it in the
time jump over to threads we may we're
up on threads oh guys
guys we're about to play a game
that we love
I think Randy loves it more than anybody
I love who's the [__] who's the
[__] I love it you know this it's a
Reddit thing so like am I an [__] am
I the [__] and I usually this is what
happens to me I change like three times
in a story okay I come in dance fun
while Dan unfolds it so he's like it's
like the show alone you know we were
talking about new episodes are up on
Netflix oh where they drop a bunch of
survivalists Into the Wilderness up in
the north by themselves and they get you
to think you know who's gonna win in the
first five minutes and you're wrong
Marine he has no Wi-fi remember the guy
who faked a heart attack no I was like
dude you're just having a panic
I agree he probably didn't himself so
there's the guy who has no kid's wife
whatever we're like he in the first day
he builds like a two-story house I'm
like why do you need why do you need a
sunken bath all right so they know who
usually wins the person who gets very
little airtime in the first episode but
you just catch when they say I love my
wife and kids I spent a lot of time away
from home like okay you're already used
to it that's who you usually wins I hate
my life more than anybody here so
there's a woman who's like there's a guy
the guy who's like whittling and you
know antlers from a moose he killed from
the boat that dropped him off and and
he's like he's he's gonna be here
forever right and then like five minutes
in the first episode like a tear forms
in his eye and he's like that squirrel
reminds me of My Dead Brother we're like
all the [__] boat he is out of here
then meanwhile there's like one woman
who's like I don't hide I just forged
for berries we're like Do not drop her
off
she lasts more longer than everyone else
they forget about her and three seasons
later they come back to the same spot
and they're like Beth oh my God oh my
God she's still here she's still here
she's open to school and how are her
pants tight she gained weight she ate 17
berries in a leech in three years all
right you ready to do it let's do it
based on the headline you can tell me
right away if you want who you think the
answer is okay I will check in vegan
bride
Furious as groom axes all veggie options
from wedding without time I'm so mad at
this groom don't do it screw you you
know who she is you like you know who
you married do this for her I'm like you
know he didn't do this story right we
didn't do the story no we've done plenty
of like weddings we did the wedding one
where the bride wanted it to be silent
we did the wedding one where the bride
and her best friend wanted their dogs to
get married at the wedding and the guy
was like we can have a separate ceremony
for the dog the weirdest man
my own story so I'm mad I'm mad right
now I'm mad at the vegan bride Furious
as groom axes all veggie options from
wedding without telling her the without
telling her apart is the hard part
trust you got it it almost feels and I
put this story in here it almost feels
like there's no way he isn't going to be
the ass well if he's possible okay there
must be something
this was good enough I will tell you how
he wouldn't be the [__] I'll flip it
vegan bride is furious at husband for
adding a meat option to their menu all
right now you're the [__] if he wants
to add a meat option
it's a marriage
okay here we go who's the [__] a
vegan bride has expressed her anger
after her husband to be decided to get
rid of every vegan option on their
wedding menu without telling her meaning
she'll have nothing to eat on her big
day at her own way they're a big day but
hers as well yeah but I mean at her own
wedding the two people be clear it's her
big day it is her big deal they are just
I have realized this weddings are normal
people's one night to be a movie star
that's it I say it's the same exactly it
is like this is my red carpet premiere
of the baby that I'm starring and I have
three outfit changes I have hair and
makeup everybody here for me the camera
the dance the ceremony like it is like
princess stardom it is like all of that
wrapped into one like it is obviously a
tool that has historically been used to
like create ownership over women but it
has also been spun into this like you're
the prince
yeah like it's well but also I would ask
anybody who doesn't you know subscribe
to this philosophy when the groom walks
down the aisle does everyone get up and
turn around no they're usually already
standing there they're already standing
already in the ring Stephen gonna lose
okay Dave pole gorgeous Jimmy Garvin
against Mike Stone
Rick Scott
the groom is Mike Stone okay of course
uh the woman explains she and most of
her family members follow a plant-based
diet and she had been planning on adding
around four or five vegan dishes to her
wedding menu alongside the meat eater
options he's the [__] so that
everyone had plenty of choice over what
they ate yes so that's what a normal
freaking person does this is this guy
Hey listen we're gonna kill them I like
you know he's she's like close to him
we're gonna kill all that we don't need
the comments we don't need the
cauliflower souffle hey like Finley
plotted out like rom-com where he's
trying to see what he can do to get her
to call it all he is a hunting blogger
yeah like this is not a person who wants
to participate in a marriage with her
her or a marriage at all at all no no
what are we doing she's waiting for the
pre-wedding photos that are supposed to
be happening with the bridal party on
the beach she texts him and he's like
I'm on hole 14. I'll be there in nine
minutes I'll be there in like 90 minutes
right like this all the guys like I'm
golfing on my on my wedding if she were
to go hey so it's over like we're not
getting married and he's like because of
because I didn't want veggies at my
[__] wedding I'd go no uh that is
obviously an issue it's that you didn't
tell me
we're supposed to pick what school our
kids go to he went on like we don't even
do this without you telling me Dan he
went on a podcast and his friends on the
podcast are like you you're having what
at your wedding and then he's like
you're gonna let her boss call the
caterer on this podcast and cut that you
gotta let her boss you around and and
put some freaking tofu up at your
wedding let me just say one thing like I
was vegan for five years I can report
live and say that veganism has changed
to a place where like plant focused like
vegetable focused dishes can be really
incredible Gracias Madre like yeah like
the cuisine has come so far like you can
do it without a spot of tofu on the
whole thing
impossible Burger I did when we were in
Austin Texas we went to P Terry's and
late night I had like a you know a
Beyond burger and a possible I couldn't
tell I would I literally any person in
Wisconsin to come eat the nachos at
Gracias Madre with me and not love them
right it's the same damn [__] okay here
we go eat that Wisconsin you're dead
he's a meat blogger those Wisconsin
people know who I'm picturing yeah but
the woman's fiance and his mom remember
because she said she wanted everybody to
have a choice over to you but the
woman's fiance and his mum were
staunchly yeah this is from the mirror
but I don't know if she is we're
staunchly against the idea claiming that
vegan food wasn't real food and
insisting that any guests who didn't
want to eat meat could just have a salad
instead I would substitute uh your ideas
aren't real ideas honey I mean the the
way that this is such a republican
ideology like the way that this is
political she's like Army
it's a real food yeah like what the [__]
after failing to reach an agreement the
bride-to-be then claimed that her future
husband decided to go behind her back
and make changes to the menu without
telling her removing all vegan options
in a post on Reddit which is where this
lives all she said when you go to Reddit
that means you're like I'm looking for
some support or a conspiracy oh no no
she wants a world of landslide of public
support so she can go back to this guy
and be like look what the world shifts
you want those too I have receipts of
those my fiance and I are getting
married soon this is what she wrote
there wasn't much that we disagreed on
during the wedding planning except for
food my family are vegans and there are
so many reasons why we chose this
lifestyle and one of them being that we
have a history of health issues my
fiance and his family are the complete
opposite they're hardcore meat eaters
which is fine by me obviously no she's
cool with it however when deciding on
the wedding food menu I wanted to add
four to five vegan options my fiance and
his mom objected saying it was a waste
of money over food that quote isn't real
food wait who's paying for the wedding
that I bet we get to that who's paying
for the wedding they also argued that
this would be offensive to their guests
who's how is that offensive and
suggested by vegan options just be quote
the good old salads and appetizers
[Music]
I said no because for one it's me and my
family who's paying
oh snap this guy doesn't even have if
you are not watching dumb people town
and rain is about to explode this guy
does not have a tofurkey leg to stand up
I there's okay I'll I'm gonna have to go
marry her that's the only way to solve
this we're gonna give her her day all
right we're gonna give her her step in
and and man up and marry this woman
you'll even allow her to be the bride at
that time
100 you don't get to watch on the island
have your moment no problem you could do
it for her but you are gonna demand her
but you are going to demand a couple
Yeah well yeah well she'd have to
converse
Judaism that's all she would yeah she
just have to give her but yeah I'll be a
vegan I don't care we're doing we're
doing zoodles as a man okay
we'll re-rack I said no because for one
it's me and my family who's paying yeah
two I want to make my guests feel
welcome and not be treated as
second-class Citizens by being served
salad
my fiance
and she said we don't want to be
second-class citizens uh by being served
salad she must have said that in quotes
because she said my fiance made a face
and said isn't that what vegans eat have
you guys ever talked have you been in
the in the I mean left in your fridge I
don't want a victim blame but at some
point in this story I'm gonna start
wondering what got you this far away
like the Kurt bronolor bit about the
woman who had a hundred thousand bees in
her world ten wasn't enough fifteen
didn't get you out of your chair you're
buzzing at 15 like 55
000 you didn't ask a neighbor do you
hear that we had 10 000 bees outside of
our which by the way is what Malcolm
Gladwell says is how many beasts you
need to master the B situation
I can understand it no but we had like a
bunch of bees were flying around like I
think there's a problem and then we are
called The Beekeeper over and he's like
you got 10 000 bees in here that was ten
thousand so like you're clearly not
paying attention to the Sciences Kurt
bronnell or would brilliantly say so
yeah so many you got this how badly do
you need to be married that you gotta
that you're putting up with this [__]
I refuse to argue about it and said it
was Final she was adding these options
yes the woman then confronted her
husband to be who claimed that she she
had failed to accommodate his family
with her menu even though there were
always meat options available at some
point she had to say you're being
impossible about this you're being
Beyond this is an issue in our society
globally why do you care how someone
lives their lives
people who are like this is the problem
people who are like I paid off all my
student loans they shouldn't get theirs
free
Dan why do you care so I that someone
else's life is made better that didn't
doesn't come in marriage does not
abolish straight marriage that's right
so I think what people are seeing right
now is that people who are victims and
actual victims are receiving a lot of
attention and so the people who are not
victims are like wait I want some of
that victim attention I'm a victim here
even though they don't eliminate my
choices make me a victim pay attention
to me it's all about it but I get if
somebody goes [__] I wish I didn't pay
mine I'd be like I hear you things
change and now this is the ultimate
going forward don't you happy they won't
have the struggle you have Dan is there
I would say to that person and anybody
who's offended by whatever plate is
sitting in front of them but whatever
plate are being ordered at this place
what is sitting in front of you probably
a T-bone steak do you care three tail
tables over that there's like a
different thing sitting in front of
another person how does that affect what
you're eating this is this this story is
the we are seeing fascism at play this
is fashion you can't be
against things like people what people
want to eat that doesn't affect you you
can't be against people getting student
loan forgiveness which they'll probably
just keep lying about so that I keep
voting for them yeah you can't get those
you can't you can't be mad at those
things and love the movie It's a
Wonderful Life nope you can't you can't
because what about all those people in
[__] George Bailey's house
it was good it was good okay okay
I'm just fighting the urge to do my name
is
bubbling up and going for it you know
what I'm gonna I am gonna overcome do it
okay here we go no I'm mad that you did
it all right you took his thing
then where was I uh paid she paid yeah
she paid so the Hurricane
by me I said no I really lost where I
was because that's the appetizers no
here I got it okay okay
she converted them with a family memory
even though they were always meet Ops
available she added I called him at work
I called him at work but he kept hanging
up on me oh I went straight to his
workplace and confronted him there and
just flipped out on him he was stunned
and by the way he was stunned to see me
you you're a woman who drove herself
here yeah literally literally he quote
he at first said it was his mom's idea
by the way if I were her friend if she
was my best friend I would say do not go
to work and go off on him also don't go
to the church don't go to work and go
off on this guy that is not even though
you have every right to really this is
not going to help you out in the since
it go off on him not at work because you
don't want him to then turn to other
people and be like see this is what she
is hysterical crazy over here don't give
him any fodder your point is correct
let's pick the right time to do this he
at first said it was it was his mom's
idea then told me to go home because I
was making a scene at the office the
fight continued at home and he defended
himself by saying that I sort of made
made him resort to doing this after I
kept brushing off his thoughts and input
and refusing to accommodate his family
the only part that's relevant is the
last part you did this because I didn't
accommodate your asinine [__] wishes
that's why she did you know why I
brushed you off because the conversation
was over when I said what his family is
pushing this is what I there's no way it
comes back his family is like if you
give in on this you're gonna give in on
everything that's how marriage works you
give in on things and they give in on
things right okay this isn't even a
given thing it's a okay no I agree
you're gonna be sleeping in pink pajamas
yeah under in a feather bed you're gonna
be married to a pig no it's literally
awesome
sounds great
she keeps writing but there were plenty
of meat options why can't I get four or
five vegan options when I'm paying for
it he yelled that it was his wedding too
not my families my family said it was
fine and they'll figure it out and told
me to let it go her family told her to
let it go but I refuse used good good
for you this woman has no allies it's a
dowry on this like what is this about
this is she then asks am I the [__]
for putting my foot down not at all
I've got an update oh baby come on oh
[__] do you think I don't even know I
don't remember do you think they ended
up getting married no no way no I pray
to God they did or the only way the
ceremony two separate receptions hey
thank you it's like no I'm joking they
only have two bathrooms yeah update so
his this is what she wrote so his mom
messaged me this is after she posts on
this earlier trying to get me to listen
to what she had to say after I kept
ignoring her phone calls she spent she
came down to my work she sent long walls
of text to to just to address what I did
at her son's workplace calling it all
kinds of stuff from immature to unhinged
do you wanna uh guess what else is then
a long wall of Tex she then went to
explain how she's noticed that me and my
family kept acting dismissive of her
son's input and contributions to the
wedding and then
I would just write back that I would
just right back to that text what input
she said that she noticed my behavior
towards him and her entire family and
wanted to speak up earlier but didn't
and oh she's such a great person yeah
and tried to keep the peace she then
went on to address the flute food menu
issue and denied her involvement in the
cancellation of the vegan option but
that didn't mean she doesn't support her
son's decision moreover she thought it
was so responsible of him to make that
move because of my continual refusal to
see how this stuff is a waste of money
can I guess the next paragraph So after
the honeymoon I said I'm not texting
your mama yeah yeah right yeah I can't
wait to see their vows she also pointed
out how I kept saying I paid for it yeah
because that you did so [__] relevant
yeah it says that's a fact that's the
shutdown argument it's at the end
technically this isn't just my money
it's mine and his because we're getting
married not yet she suggested I wisen up
and get rid of my and get rid of quote
my money I paid for it mentality
so how things work so if I'm her I say
all of this sounds great
thank you for sending this note this is
the last you will not see your
grandchildren oh my God oh my God you go
into your grave wishing you had met your
grandchildren and as you go as they're
lowering your casket
lowering your headphones into the grave
you everyone around will be like what
was her relationship with her
grandchildren she didn't have
yeah yeah your gravestone's only going
to say wife mother yes
in your obituary is going to be very
short grandmother crossed out no my when
your grandkids say where are you going
today this Sunday morning Mom say I'm
meeting a friend for a thing yeah your
future I'm going to a party
enjoy being a member of the red hat yes
and not talking about yeah she finally
mentioned how bad this whole situation
is making me look and said that she and
her son had already offered a number of
compromises salad that I chose to brush
off and decided to when they get married
a weird I decided to make it my weird
Hill to die on weird there's so much
condensation oh God condensation and con
love it just got to send a Dan for his
eyes
she said that not only her son is upset
oh I care but she and the family are as
well after hearing about it and
suggested I just agree on their
compromise it's not a weird heel to die
on you're dying on your Hill this pissed
me off beyond belief sure I responded by
letting her know that I'm still standing
my ground on this even if I have to call
the whole wedding off because of police
because of it because honestly this is
just ridiculous it is my mom and dad
they don't even know what to say anymore
apparently my fiance saw my two weeks
from her only eating vegan food
apparently my fiance saw my response to
her because he's with her right now and
is now trying to call me but right now
I'm waiting on him to get home and see
if he's still insisting on The Stance he
took at some point
that's too much leeway at some point she
is an idiot she's got it she's also dumb
this really upsets me because it just
speaks to like how many women clearly
feel that they need to get married they
need to get married
life that's right to meet some sort of a
standard how could I risk the
embarrassment of calling off a wedding
how could I you know like all the
invitations are already out fear-based
uh like motivations for Life Choices
that are so big and that they would put
themselves in a situation that is so
deeply disrespected three years and that
I'm being generous in three years no one
will care what your wedding was like
yeah and no one will care that you
called it off not not one and I'm being
generous right people love you they'll
go oh yeah great good for you you dodged
up dodged a meat flavored bullet
I mean we'll get out of here how old how
old are they are they the same update
Dan that's there that was the updated so
we've been out fighting with the mom
okay all right how old are they both yes
are they the same age I'll go first and
then you you can go either second or
third uh she's
34. okay and he's 29. okay five years
split there
um
she's vegan her whole family's vegan his
family they're still I love that she's
doing the math in her head out loud this
is like a beautiful line they have the
meats Carrie the did you say carry the
two yeah
um I love about it I'm gonna go ahead
and say that she is
Randy 32. okay she's 32. and he is
35. okay so 35 32 and I think the other
way 29 is the guy and 34 is the game 30
is the guy okay 27 is the woman okay
the ages I will give them an order of
him and then her okay R get your answers
in now tell me I'm very curious I don't
want you to like I'm not going to
interact with you but if you think he's
right just I would love to hear a case
make the case make the case I just want
to know if there's any person I'm not
happy for them if they are this person
but if there's any person who thinks
he's right that would that would also
blow my mind blow my mind okay
he is
31. oh I said 30. you said 30. she is
he's a boy who needs to grow up and
she's a girl who has her whole life in
front girl you're 25. you have so much
ahead you don't need this go have a life
go have a summer all right there you go
that's uh Story number one down the
books when we come back we'll find out
what everybody here is doing and
everybody has going on so you can follow
support watch and love this dumb people
town with our lovely lovely friend
Hannah Ein binder who I love love I'm so
happy she's here we'll be right back
[Music]
down
hey guys want to talk about our
wonderful sponsor fitbod look wherever
you are in your fitness journey maybe
you made goals and you hadn't hit them
maybe you life was busy you hadn't
thought of goals you wanted to make or
maybe you've been on a journey and
you're actually doing Fitness throughout
the year uh I love fitbod because they
build a workout plan based on what
materials you have what equipment you
have and where you are in your journey
you can do so I was like in a bit of an
exercise rut I'm like I don't know what
I want to do I don't want to join a gym
right now I really don't I don't want to
drive to a gym do this I want to do a
workout that I can do at home off my
phone at home and so fitbod perfect the
app is so easy to use they tailor make
these great workouts for you with the
stuff that you have and so maybe you
have some dumbbells maybe you have a
kettlebell maybe you have resistance
bands whatever you've got they will help
you do it the right way yeah show you
the exercise the right way and to me
it's been it's been so fun because they
track your progress in a good way but
also like thing you were saying about
like uh kind of finding yourself like in
a rut or like the stuff you were doing
like wasn't enough that happens for
people who like work out a lot too yeah
where I'm like I just do 30 minutes on
the elliptical and then I do buys and
tries or whatever yes and you kind of
like Plateau they help you with that
because fitbot's powerful technology
understands your strength training
ability studies your past workouts and
adapts your available gym uh equipment
so you can keep your gym sessions fresh
and fun by mixing up so if you go to a
gym and you actually belong to a gym you
can actually use fitbods work 100 take
it there with you as well it's awesome
wherever you are in your fitness journey
get the most out of every workout with
fitbot you can get 20 off your
subscription at fitbod.me DPT guys it's
20 off and it's f i t b o d dot m e
slash d p t do it
so summertime is here and we're all sort
of figuring out ways that we can just
get out and have around have fun and get
places and experience really cool things
and I know Dan you're having the best
time dude with your brand new electric
e-bike you love it so much and tell them
how you're using it yeah oh I'm using it
in my dreams okay and real life at my
cabin in Wisconsin amazing okay first of
all it is so light I easily got it in
the car and got it foldable some of them
can the model uh the model that I
haven't done but I always tell people
about that one you can get them so great
too yeah you can add on like an extra
seat onto it so you can have somebody
ride in the back you can add baskets to
it you can get a great like I have a
great like I ordered a a great like cell
phone holder I upgraded because we're up
in the cabin at the woods I upgraded the
headlight for it the one that comes on
though is awesome like I might that
might have been a little bit Overkill
but you never know what these deer think
about the uh you might be going fast Dan
dude you so the way it works right is
like if you're on like the zero setting
you're pedaling more to keep the motor
generated and then you can go up to the
five setting to where you don't do
anything except turn the throttle and
yeah you can go I'm going over like 20
miles an hour
the batteries and you can also add an
extra one but even the one they did like
two weeks without me having to recharge
it amazing it really is just
like it's a game changer it's like you
know what it is it is one of those
things I was like
I'm glad I waited because I got electric
but I'm like why did my family not have
one of these yeah so much like
everything is so much more fun you need
to run to the store to get something
right away
go down to the lake and back go for a
ride and you know what else is really
cool my aunt and uncle in their 60s they
as soon as I I went for a first run they
both hopped on it and went for a run I
love it but Aunt Connie didn't come back
for like 10 minutes
but you know at first they were like
okay how's this work but instantly Anna
and loving it oh yeah so I want to tell
you about the eggs so great the Xbox
they really are great worth every penny
amazing most popular e-bike in the
industry newly reimagined starting at
999.28 mile per hour top speed which is
Trucking new hydraulic brakes for
smoother stopping experience look they
have all types of bikes for you as Dan
mentioned the kind that fold the kind
that you can keep adding details you
want to zip around you want to have a
little fun that XP is perfect if you've
got like a family or stuff you want to
like take around
the cargo Expedition series is amazing
that's what I have it is so great so
tell them what to do three pounds so I
will tell you guys what to do ReDiscover
your Independence this summer with an XP
3.0 from Electric you visit
electricebikes.com to learn more and
explore these epic models electric has
to offer that's electric
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com you're gonna
you will love it yeah
stick around
all right so I've got the final story
I'm gonna bring us home you ready you
guys ready sent by in by Jake groney at
jakegroney gross Jake
British man who went missing in Kenya
found in Pub after four days why would
you not check there guys number one spot
British man goes missing check all the
pubs that's my first thing they love to
drink they love to where's the last
place you saw it it's a famous thing
about them and you know what and they
famously and beautifully fulfill that
prophecy but was he drinking there for
four days a British man who was missing
for four days has been found drinking in
a pub well that is the question so wait
so I think more people are found missing
because of how connected we are with
cell phones and with like I think back
in the day guy we don't hear from from
three or four days no one's worried
unless until it becomes two weeks oh
yeah like I mean this is like Devil in
the White City it just used to be like
people who left the rural communities
and went into the city to the you
understood when they left you just may
never hear from them right and we don't
know nothing may happen and you'll never
know and you just live the rest of your
life till they pop up they died or maybe
they went and lived a whole new life but
now yes there's a lot more connectivity
so I but Randy and I on on Fourth of
July went to our cousin's house down in
Mission Viejo and it was so fun and so
sweet right before the fireworks right
before the fireworks so like the thing
we're building towards today and my you
my wife and my daughter and my son and
in Randy's whole family or minus his
daughters at Camp we're all there and
all these people there excited to see
the fireworks which are right over their
house it's so great so close and
someone's like where's the dog the other
dog there's one of the two dogs and
we're like I cannot find the dog
anywhere
right before the fireworks so you know
that's gonna freak them out so so then
the fireworks start and it's like well
you're not gonna find this thing like
you're never going to find this stuff so
we're running up and down the street and
we're walking around and it's like the
scene from Boogie Nights where like the
firecrackers are being guys dropping
firecrackers boom boom boom and we're
running around panicked and then like I
stopped to watch the fireworks for like
30 seconds with my kids but I also don't
want to seem like I'm not caring about
this dog that's missing but I do want to
watch Fire by the way PostScript we did
find the dog he was at a pub in Kenya
and it didn't take us four [__] days
yeah he is an English bulldog
but I like that
he's an Irish Senator
it's obviously he's obviously he was
wasted no uh so we did find the dog
thankfully but this is like but it
ruined it completely ruined the
fireworks and for an hour and a half we
all were like this dog is gone yeah I'm
like I think an eagle flew down
that was my theory Eagle picked him up
I'm gonna tell you this British man's
name and you're gonna be like this is
the most British name I've ever heard my
entire life okay
Bartleby
bottle drinks yes Bartleby McKenzie yeah
whatever whatever whatever
um
apparently Bartleby McKenzie I can I
guess even though I know that I have to
go last yeah
Dan you got one what's his name
Rutherford Rutherford
Scotchman
I'm gonna say anglo-saxton
you just gotta commit what's what's the
British name that you're thinking
anything I'm gonna say
William
[Music]
Buckle buckleton's worth
I say Rupert Rupert Pendleton also might
be very good sorry guys Nelson Newberry
I mean all right two streets since the
since Tuesday the Britain had not been
seen since heading out to get a sim
replacement chart
this is a dude who's like from the
minute he bought his new iPhone thing he
was having problems with like he got a
bomb iPhone from the beginning and he
gave me a bum yeah
detectives from the crime research and
intelligence Bureau stormed the pub on
the outskirts of Nairobi where they
found Mr Newberry sharing mugs of local
beer why do you need to storm that pup
yeah was that really necessary
the door we don't need to storm we don't
need a storm apart why do they think he
was in Kenya the kid has been since
you've been he's kid who reunited with
his father who flew out to Kenya to meet
his son and I'm sure he was happy to
outlay the money to do that yeah in this
day and age and in this economy yeah he
has also taken taken the hospital for
treatment and image shared by Kenya's
directorate of criminal investigations
appeared to show Mr nunenberry with some
facial injuries this would be to me a
great movie script four days in Nairobi
come on I'd do that a British citizen
who's been missing since Tuesday has
been found by detectives finally our
long National nightmare is over they
wrote that no that's what I say the 22
year old man identified as Nelson
Newberry was found a local pub in uh
etheru uh ituru no he was in Kenya so
this is my thing I would love it if they
found him and they did like a medical
check on him and he has like three
kidneys now right like he's got an extra
show you a picture of the kid who got
found so there he is in a Dior shirt in
a Dior shirt and his dad and he has no
right that's just future aged Miles
Teller
wait a second so he's kind of beating up
do you know
wait a minute
bit what happened something happened
fight like to me what would be [__] up
and awesome this is what would make a
good movie is if he doesn't know what
happens and he's got to figure out it's
like it's like The Hangover yeah exactly
right so let's so he was lost no one
checked all the pubs maybe because they
don't know where the pubs are in like or
he was or he got kidnapped or something
happened to him and he broke free and
remember doing Moshe casher's show and
his friend talked about being kidnapped
in like Mexico or somewhere like that
and it was I mean he talked escaped from
being kidnapped and walked back to the
Locked Up Abroad type stuff yeah he was
like he had no shoes and he walked like
50 miles and I mean it's insane so maybe
that happened to this kid but they found
him how old will get out of here on this
how old is Nelson Newberry you already
saw the picture of him but how old do
you think he is 18. 18 what do you think
22 24 one of you is exactly right he's
22. you think he's 22. you want to stay
outside you're sticking on 18. okay
get your answers in townies because
Nelson Newberry is
22 years old oh Daniel do you like how I
looked at her and it was his yeah
so that is it so I guess listen I mean
check the pub that should be the scores
today check the pub
check your followers yeah and and check
to make sure that your husband isn't
gonna like yeah your future husband
isn't gonna get rid of all your vegan
options at your wedding that you're
paying for that you're paying for that
you're paying for there you go that is a
show if you're uh in the fall go see
Hannah Ein binder on better uh go see
Daniel on all the dates that he's doing
he's taping in Chicago 11 11 we're not
going to forget that and then come see
us we have a bunch of dates and stuff we
love you guys and oh [__] we gotta get
back to work peace
town
[Music]